a ver intenta resolver está integral
ya lo intentaste bueno entonces vamos a
trabajar en este ejercicio juntos
seguramente te diste cuenta que no hay
ninguna técnica tradicional que hayamos
visto que se aplique directamente a esta
integral por ejemplo hacer una
sustitución no nos va a servir de nada y
muchas de las otras técnicas tampoco nos
van a ayudar
el chiste aquí es notar que esto de aquí
es una expresión racional es una
división de dos expresiones algebraicas
donde además el grado del numerador es
mayor o igual que el grado del
denominador en este caso en particular
son exactamente iguales ahora cuando
tenemos estas expresiones racionales lo
que tenemos que hacer es la división
algebraica en la que tomamos este
numerador x menos 5 y dividimos esta
expresión algebraica entre el
denominador menos 2x
2 ok y hacemos una simple división de
expresiones algebraicas entonces para
hacer esta división nos fijamos en los
términos de mayor grado o sea estos dos
términos y nos preguntamos cuántas veces
cabe menos dos equis y pues cabe menos
un medio veces cierto menos un medio ok
entonces multiplicamos menos un medio
por todo esto
menos un medio por dos es menos uno
menos uno luego menos un medio por menos
dos x menos con menos es más y luego dos
por un medio es uno así es que nos queda
simplemente una equis entonces a x 5 le
tenemos que restar x menos 1
así es que ponemos el menos por aquí y
menos por menos gusta más y nos queda
pues estas x se cancelan y nos queda
simplemente menos x más 1 que es un
menor
4 y esta división algebraica lo que nos
dice es que podemos escribir a todo esto
de aquí como menos un medio menos un
medio más menos 4 entre menos 2 x más 2
- 2 x más 2
todo esto es igual a esta fracción de
aquí y lo queremos integrar con respecto
a x y ahora lo que vamos a hacer es
simplificar esta expresión de aquí o sea
porque por ejemplo esta fracción podemos
ver claramente que el 2 divide tanto el
numerador como a todos los términos del
denominador entonces vamos a dividir
arriba y abajo entre 2 y además también
nos podemos deshacer de este símbolo
menos el numerador entonces pues vamos a
hacerlo a ver estamos dividiendo
numerador y denominador entre menos 2
entonces menos 4 entre menos 2
todo esto de aquí se convierte en un 2 y
aquí en el denominador menos 2 x entre
menos 2 pues es simplemente una equis y
luego 2 entre menos 2 se convierte en un
menos 1 pero bueno aquí ya quedó todo
muy amontonado entonces vamos a volver a
escribirlo y observa que lo único que
hemos hecho aquí son puras cosas
algebraicas aunque simplemente la
división algebraica y luego un poco de
simplificación de esta fracción aunque
bueno algunos dirían que esto no es
simplificar una fracción pero resulta
que es muchísimo más fácil integrar
estos dos términos que este entonces
tenemos por aquí menos un medio
2 en el numerador entre x x menos uno
menos uno y estamos integrando con
respecto a x
entonces queremos evaluar esta integral
y bueno la anti derivada de menos un
medio es súper sencilla es simplemente
menos un medio x bueno pero cuál es la
anti derivada de dos entre x menos 1
haber ya lo pensaste bueno pues la
derivada de x menos 1 es simplemente un
1 entonces suena que tenemos a esta
constante 2 x justo la derivada del
logaritmo natural del valor absoluto de
x menos 1 cierto donde estamos
utilizando cuál es la derivada del
logaritmo natural y una sustitución
donde la uv es igual a x menos uno y de
y está por aquí arriba que en realidad
es un 1 por de x pero bueno como esto
parece que está quedando muy confuso voy
a hacerlo paso por paso veamos queremos
saber cuál es la anti derivada de dos
entre x menos 1
con respecto a equis y estamos diciendo
que vamos a hacer una sustitución donde
x1 es igual a 1 x menos 1 y entonces
cuando derivamos aquí nos queda de x
x 0 así es que esta integral es igual a
la integral de una vez por todas podemos
sacar este 2 aquí afuera 2 por la
integral de 1 / ahora x menos 1 ahora se
llama
y de equis ahora se llama de y entonces
ponemos de un
bueno y aquí ya podemos utilizar
directamente lo que sabemos del
logaritmo entonces esto es igual aquí
tenemos este 2 que no se nos debe de
olvidar 2 y la anti derivada de esto es
el logaritmo del valor absoluto de eeuu
y tampoco se nos vaya a olvidar que
tenemos que sumarle una constante ahora
por aquí no tenemos ni un término que se
llame entonces queremos dejarlo todo en
términos de la x así es que tenemos que
sustituir eso de que es igual a x menos
1 y nos queda simplemente como 2 por el
logaritmo del valor absoluto de x menos
1 más la constante muy bien muy bien así
es que por aquí la anti derivada de 2 /
x menos uno es igual a 2 por el
logaritmo del valor absoluto de x 1
valor absoluto
siempre que tengamos una integral no se
nos puede olvidar poner esta constante
al final si estuviéramos yendo en el
otro sentido osea si tuviéramos esta
expresión y derivar amos pues la
derivada de todo esto sería estuve aquí
y la derivada de la constante siempre es
cero así es que ya terminamos este es
nuestro resultado